hi you know one of the great things
about link is our community language
learners from all over the world I've
already mentioned to you that you can
have your writing corrected on the
exchange by our members you can have
online discussions with native speakers
you yourself can also help others in the
same way you will have noticed that the
lessons in our library have been
contributed by our members you can do
the same you can perhaps record a
conversation with your friend or your
spouse and have it transcribed you can
maybe indicate on our forum some of the
resources that exist for the language
that you're learning on our forum people
often offer answers to questions that
learners have about their native
language there are so many different
ways that you can help others and that
others can help you try to familiarize
yourself with these or ask questions on
our forum and you will see that it's a
very supportive community that will help
you achieve your language learning goals